alright this is gonna take some serious
thought I might stand contemplation for
reals you can stand up if you want sure
is that legal
I want to keep it I want to keep it in
justice we can't possibly decide about
this Chippendales Chips Ahoy thing what
do people call you for short or do they
use your whole first night every time
Jay Jay brings it back to the whole weed
thing Yeah right what else are you i
calling you not in chambers respect my
chambers you want some cookies yeah this
ramekin very cute I like it too
Oh Chippendales more like Chips Ahoy but
I think both of those guys sell that
joke on a nightly basis oh no his closer
was was like a Dorito bit like a frito
Lake Doritos more like full of O's
I used to beep everybody but now I've
ever been this guy's dad was coming up
with a million of them wait a minute a
thousand dollars like I've got jokes and
I think a lot of them are funny but I
don't know if I could put a price point
on one of my shitty jokes and gee that's
what I'm saying
if you're friends and you say something
funny and one comedian says hey can I
have that you either go sure or 50 bucks
50 bucks
[Music]